so ist einer der grössten youtuber
deutschland hat vor zwei tagen das
wahrscheinlich krasseste youtube video
auf seinem kanal hochgeladen in dem er
sich geoutet hat und ich habe das
gesehen habe mich im ersten moment
erstmal richtig für ihn gefreut weil ich
mir irgendwie vorstellen kann das ist
großer schritt für ihn ist sehr sehr
befreiend sein kann ich habe viele kurze
weile gar nicht weiter dabei gedacht bis
ich in das video auch mal wirklich rein
geschaut habe und gesehen habe dass er
in diesem video über sachen reden die
nicht nur ihn betreffen sondern die
gedanken und gefühle sind die sehr sehr
viele menschen da draußen haben und
deswegen habe ich mich dazu entschieden
dazu eine reaction zu machen weil ich
hoffe dass ich wenn ich die gedanken die
das video in mir ausgelöst habe euch
mitteilen ich vielleicht diese ganze
debatte noch ein bisschen weiter treiben
kann euch auch zeigen kann wie ich über
das thema nachdenken und deswegen heute
liegen jetzt los
[Musik]
das ist das ist wirklich auch das ist
tatsächlich ein richtig schweres video
weil es auch schwer ist die richtigen
worte dafür zu finden was man als
außenstehender dazu sagen kann ich habe
mir auch tatsächlich eine weile gedacht
kann ich überhaupt irgendetwas
sinnvolles dazu beitragen oder ist das
eigentlich auch wird auf youtube ist
eigentlich sein privater moment der für
ihn ist aber genau dann kam eben der
gedanke den er auch gleich verstehen
werdet wenn ihr hören weil der hostie in
diesem video sagt weil er da wirklich
immer sachen sprich die auch mich
persönlich irgendwo betreffen wo ich
mich personen betroffen davon gefühlt
habe und ich eben auch denke dass einige
von euch ist auch so geht und sieht
irgendwie diese zweifel in sich haben
und deswegen finde ich dass dieses video
wichtig
das ist so holz im alter wie geht es im
moment so gut wie noch nie zuvor in
meinem leben ich fühle mich so geliebt
wie man sich nur wünschen kann
ich kann dazwischen sagen dass ich im
grunde alles in meinem leben erreicht
habe weil ich immer wollte und damit
meine ich nicht gelten schönes haus
autos und so weiter
damit meine ich das gefühl wertvollste
seien der grund dafür zu sein dass
jemand lebt ohne krass also man muss
erst mal sagen ich freue mich richtig
krass für fergie dass er diesen punkt
erreicht hat und jetzt kommen wir dazu
was ich meinte leute weil ich persönlich
für mich selbst dieses gefühl irgendwie
noch nicht habe und ich glaube viele von
euch haben dass da draußen auch noch
nicht dass man irgendwie angekommen ist
oder dass man genug ist so als mensch
versteht ihr was ich meine
das ist irgendwie so ein ding das diesen
punkt habe ich noch nicht erreicht umso
mehr freue ich mich für joe aber umso
wichtiger finde ich auch dass alle leute
die das hier sehe und sich denken ich
will das auch irgendwie warum ist das
bei mir noch nicht passiert dieses video
im sehen ohne dass ich irgendwas
bestimmtes macher sondern indem ich
einfach nur da bin und so lange in
meinem leben habe ich geglaubt dass ich
dieses gefühl niemals haben werde
das ist echt crazy das zu sehen also wie
gesagt die idee finde ich richtig geil
dass das bei dir so ist fettes
kompliment auch dafür dass du diesen
großen schritt gemacht hast weil ich
kann mir vorstellen dass es wirklich ein
großer schritt für ihn gewesen ist auch
wenn wir in 2021 leben und sehr sehr
viele leute schon tolerant gegenüber
diesem thema sind viele sind eben noch
nicht und selbst wenn alle da draußen
das in ihren eigenen köpfen vielleicht
wären ihr wisst ja nicht was manche
leute die in der position sind sich
überlegen soll ich das jetzt
veröffentlicht solches nicht
veröffentlicht sich denken im
zweifelsfall ist er selbst jetzt gerade
auch von der reaktion vielleicht
überwältigt dass so viele leute im
zuspruch geben also manchmal ist man
auch in seinem eigenen kopf gefangen ich
lade inzwischen seit über fünf jahren
videos auf diesem kanal hoch und ich
liebe was ich mache
ich habe mich noch nie so gut mit einer
sache geführt
so sinnvoll der reiche mit meiner art
und meinem humor jede woche tausende
menschen und so viele schreiben mit
täglich dass ich sie nach langer zeit
wieder zum lachen bringen konnte sie
aufgebaut habe ihm mut geschenkt habe in
den raum geboten habe alles negative
kurz zu vergessen so viele menschen den
ich helfen kann ohne irgendetwas dafür
zu tun als einfach ich zu sein in dem
ich stopp an der stelle mal wollte weil
ich will wie gesagt viel so meine
persönliche sichtweise auch darauf
einfließen lassen das ist noch eine
sache die ich auf jeden fall in meinem
leben noch suche und wenn ich das jetzt
sage dann sind es wirklich da sind
wirklich sehr sehr private gedanken aber
auch nur dass es angemessen wenn man
sich so ein video anschaut in reaktion
darauf macht diesen punkt muss ich sagen
danach strebe ich auch noch und das wäre
natürlich crazy wenn man denen in seinem
leben mal erreichen würde sage ich mal
so und trotzdem gehe ich so auf den
speed und frage mich wofür sich am
nächsten morgen eigentlich lohnt
aufzustehen
aber das fühlt sich manchmal so an als
würde sich eine riesige tief dunkle
wolkendecke über mich ziehen die mich
verfolgt egal wohin ich mich bewege die
alle positiven gefühle verblassen lässt
unsinnig erscheinen lässt ich fühle mich
in diesem moment so klein wie sich ein
mensch nur fühlen kann all das das
klingt wiederum crazy so also ich bin
jetzt gerade so gute leute wie soll ich
das jetzt sagen das ist auch nicht
leicht für mich so also ich will es mal
so sagen das ist auch ein gefühl mit dem
ich durchaus für leighton kann so das
irgendwie irgendwas negatives darüber
schreibt er wird uns gleich sagen was
ist für ihn persönlich aber was das
ausgelöst hat aber er kann ich
tatsächlich aktuell auch dazu die letten
die leute die ja ich sage mal so die
leute denen es vielleicht aktuell auch
nicht so gut geht wie können wir glaube
ich zu retten und wissen auch was der
name dafür ist hätte man einen schalter
umgelegt und ich stürzte mich in
emotionen und erinnerungen die ich schon
längst hinter mir lassen wollte
dieses video mache ich für mich in
momenten in denen ich mich wieder
vergessen vergessen wer ich bin was mich
ausmacht und warum ich so stolz auf mich
sein kann
in momenten in denen meine ängste mich
festhalten und ich nicht mehr verstehen
kann warum ich so geliebt und
wertgeschätzt werde das ist für also das
ist wirklich so ein krasses video leute
das ist so ein krasses video muss man
wirklich sagen also wir auf youtube als
youtuber wollen ja oftmals einfach nur
unterhalten aber das video macht so viel
mehr als nur unterhalten
das ist das ist wirklich wahr
super positives kind und das habe ich
auch schon immer nach außen getragen ich
habe es schon immer geliebt dafür
verantwortlich zu sein wenn ihr mit 16
grinsen nicht verkneifen konnten wenn
jemand lacht geht es ihm gut und das
überträgt sich auf mich ich kann mir
kein schöneres gefühl vorstellen meine
mutter meinte letztens zu mir dass ich
als kind so unbeschwert war immer genau
wusste was ich will und das auch nie
unnötig in frage gestellt haben und ich
war kurz verwirrt weil ich mich selbst
alles andere als unbeschwert und
selbstsicher einschätzen würde hätte ich
mit sechs jahren tanzend in der garage
meiner eltern
das ist also ich weiß ich hab mich
gerade heute bis heute fragt mich gerade
ob es richtig ist dieses video
anzuschauen und dann irgendwie zu sagen
was ich selbst wie wir dabei denkt oder
was meine gedanken dabei sind aber mehr
kann ich jetzt gerade auch irgendwie
nicht machen und ja auch das kann ich
zum gewissen maß fühlen muss ich sagen
ich glaube so geht es vielen aber dass
man irgendwie dass leute von außen auf
einen drauf stand und sich denken so
krass der person geht er so gut die hat
das ja das und ja das und dann schaust
du irgendwie mal in den kopf von den
rein wenn das geht dann weißt du auch
okay das ist ja doch bisschen anders als
ich mit sechs jahren tanzend in der
garage meiner eltern pirouetten gedreht
habe meinte sie zu einer freundin sie
glaubte ich würde mein spiel werden
irgendwie hätte sie so ein gefühl wenn
ich darüber nachdenke wie ich mich in
meiner schulzeit gefühlt habe denke ich
man komplett gegensätzliche emotionen
einmal den klassenclown der sich täglich
für die unterhaltung der gesamten
schulklasse bereit erklärt hat und
deswegen täglich mindestens 30 minuten
vor dem treffen auch den letzten
verkneifen konnte irgendwann bestimmt
immer noch lacht und das auch schon
gereicht hat
auf der anderen seite sehe ich jemanden
der zwar älter ist aber überhaupt nicht
mehr weiß wer eigentlich das was ihn
ausmacht warum er sich plötzlich so
schlecht fühlt und gar keinen richtigen
grund dafür kennt ich kann natürlich
schwer einschätzen ob das ob das vielen
oder jedem so geht die dieses video
sehen dass die sich darin wiederfinden
können aber also das ist irgendwie auch
soja das ist auch so ein ding bei mir
ich meine spieler auch auf youtube für
euch so der der entertainer so der
lustige strahlemann das ist eine jobs
macht so aber gibt eben auch eine andere
seite
ich habe so lange
dass ich mich plötzlich zu allen anderen
unterscheidet aber ich habe es nicht
gewusst ich konnte nicht verstehen was
genau mich so fühlen lässt dass ich
schwul sein könnte konnte ich aber schon
mal ausschließen in wäre das der fall
wäre ich wirklich jemand für den sich
meine eltern schämen müssten und mit dem
niemand was zu tun haben will gekommen
ist war ich davon fest überzeugt sagen
die doch immer alle über solche leute
und ich bin ja kein ekliger mensch das
weiß ich aber ich wusste nicht warum ich
mich trotzdem so anders als alle geführt
haben das ist aber das ist echt krass
leute sollen wenn ich jetzt hier oft
stoffe aber ich habe irgendwie so oft in
dem video punkten wo ich auch was dazu
sagen will das ist immer das ist
wirklich wirklich krass und das wollen
sie auch mal noch mal auf der zunge
zergehen lassen dass das im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert im jahr
2021 noch so ist dass leute immer auf
diese assoziation in ihrem kopf drin
haben dass leute immer noch die
blockaden so in ihrem kopf drin haben
und selbst leute die ja so fühlen sich
selbst blockieren dabei weil die denken
das ist irgendwas schlechtes oder das
ist falsch dass das finde ich wirklich
krass so als würde ich nicht dazu
gehören obwohl ich doch alles probiert
hatte um wie jeder andere zu sein vor
allem in der masse unterzugehen und
nicht heraus verständlich wenn doch mal
ein aber dieses gefühl ging nie weg in
der oberstufe habe ich mich dafür
entschieden mir einen gefallen zu tun
indem ich meine freundschaft nicht mehr
gepflegt habe ich dachte mir
unterbewusst bevor jemand sagt die
komische mich findet und dass er
deswegen nichts mit mir zu tun haben
will distanziere ich mich lieber vorher
selber erspare ihm die unangenehme
situation
schließlich bin ich ja hier anscheinend
das problem ja das ist so krank
das ist wirklich so dass das was da für
uns selbst ja fast schon selbst hast
schon traurigerweise in den leuten in
den kopf von den leuten drin ist dass es
wirklich hardcore das ist wirklich
traurig und das ist nicht trauriger dem
sinne dass den leuten irgendeinen
vorwurf zu machen ist was es den leuten
das hat sie auch komisch an aber den
menschen die das fühlen irgend ein
vorwurf zu machen ist aber es ist
irgendwie
ich ja es ist einfach so dass es so ist
muss man einfach so sagen ist hier ich
bin ziemlich gut darin dass zu
verstecken was ich gerade wirklich fühle
mit den fingern schnipsen und sehe super
glücklich aus ich glaube jemand aus
meiner schulzeit hat wirklich gemerkt
was in dieser zeit mit mir los war
vielleicht habe ich ab und zu ein
bisschen desinteressiert oder fehl am
platz gehört vielleicht habe ich auch
einige würfe eingebildet und arrogant
gehalten weil ich mich plötzlich nicht
mehr in ihrem umfeld aufgehalten habe
aber ich bin mir ziemlich sicher dass
ich nicht unglücklich oder gebrochen
gewirkt habe als würde ich mein
komplettes leben in frage stellen hast
du gar nicht so richtig warum ich das
hier eigentlich noch tue also irgendwie
ich weiß es nicht leute ich hoffe dass
ich jetzt auch ihm nicht unrecht damit
tue dass ich sage dass ich das an
manchen punkten halt irgendwie fühle
weil irgendwie irgendwie kann ich das
schon nachvollziehen ich weiß nicht ob
das so geht aber dass man wirklich unten
in den kommentaren rein ich weiß nicht
ob ihr euch aus gefühlt aber ich kenne
ich zu so vielen punkten wie leighton
ich hoffe dass ich das so sage auch bei
so einem thema aber ich habe mich so
gefühlt so lange das ist immer noch weh
tut wenn ich darüber nachdenke ich bin
in einem umfeld aufgewachsen in dem es
nicht okay war schwul zu sein in dem
menschen die nicht heterosexuell waren
vermeintlich nicht existierten in solche
menschen gibt es nur im fernsehen wenn
darüber kann man nur lachen oder sich
schämen
seit die nach der schule keine
perspektive mehr sehen konnte weil ich
mich leer und sinnlos gefühlt habe weil
ich so lange so sehr versucht habe dazu
zu gehören aber es nicht geschafft habe
habe ich mich dazu entschlossen ganz
weit weg zu gehen
das ist wirklich so ein thema und damit
socgen auf jeden fall sehr sehr viele
leute zumindest sehr sehr viele davon
könnte ich mir vorstellen die in dem
puncto irgendwie das gefühl haben ihre
eigene sexualität oder ihre interessen
ihre zwischenmenschlichen vorlieben und
einfach wer sie sind nicht ausleben zu
können
aber ich glaube diesen punkt haben leute
auch in abgeschwächter form auch in
anderen bereichen dass sie einfach
ausgeführten sie können nicht sie selbst
sein soll
wenn ende 2013 nach australien gereist
um ein leben in dem ich mich so fühlte
als ob mich niemand dort haben wollte
hinter mir zu lassen um auf niemanden
mehr an gewesen zu sein und endlich
stolz darauf sein zu können derjenige zu
sein der diese sieben monate in
australien waren die einsamsten und
traurigsten monate meines lebens ich
habe mich mein ganzes leben lang nicht
so alleingelassen und ungeliebt gefühlt
und das lag nicht daran dass man andere
gesagt haben wie komisch und eklig sie
diesen schulen typen fanden denn ich
habe niemanden dort auch mal ansatzweise
gezeigt wer in der jury wirklich war
alles ob das video echt krass das ist
wirklich eines der krassesten videos die
jemals gesehen habe wie youtube und ich
habe wirklich wirklich viele videos
gesehen aber das hat so viel power
deshalb so viel ehrlichkeit von ihm da
drinnen man kann so tief in ihnen
reinschauen mit dem was er da über sich
preisgibt das ist wirklich möglich krass
leute ich hoffe dass die menschen die
das auch gesehen haben das auch
verstehen und ich glaube die haben es
auch verstanden wenn ich mir die
kommentare so anschaue alles was ich
getan habe war niemand uns verlassen zu
wollen niemanden das gefühl zu geben und
dem ich so sehr angst hatte sich unwohl
in meiner gegenwart füllen zu müssen
in dieser zeit war ich ein gebrochener
mensch und ich hatte keinen blassen
schimmer mehr wer ich war und was mich
als menschen ausmacht ich habe damit
abgeschlossen jemals das gefühl zu
spüren von einer anderen person geliebt
werden und meinen mitmenschen geschätzt
zu werden dass sich freunde haben würde
die mich anrufen und fragen ob ich zeit
mit ihnen verbringen würde
ich habe damit abgeschlossen jemals ein
ganz normales leben wie jeder andere
führen zu können
ich muss ich muss ich muss kein bisschen
ich muss kurz schmunzeln weil ich
einfach nicht gecheckt habe auf was ich
mich eingelassen habe ist dieses video
aufgenommen habe dass das ist wirklich
zu krass also diesen punkt und ich hoffe
ihr gewährt mir auch dass ich das sage
und wie auch immer leute ich will es
einfach sagen ich das kann ich komplett
fühlen so weil diese angst verstoßen zu
werden alles andere in meinem leben über
bogen hat ziemlich irrational davon
auszugehen dass wirklich jeder mensch
auf der ganzen welt einen grund dafür
hätte dich kacke zu finden ich stelle
mir mal ein bisschen vor
es ist acht jahre später und ich bin die
glücklichste version von mir selbst die
man sich nur vorstellen kann
dieses vermeintliche problem das für
mich unüberwindbar erschienen was mich
glauben liest das ganz normale gefühle
wie liebe für mich unerreichbar sein hat
sich komplett in luft aufgelöst
ich habe eine familie die mich in allem
unterstützt was ich tue die mich liebt
so wie ich bin
deren liebe ich auch wieder sehen und
spüren kann ich habe freunde die mich
besser kennen als ich mich selbst ich
bin seit mehreren jahren in einer
glücklichen beziehung und letztes jahr
mit meinem freund in unser erstes
gemeinsames haus gezogen
geil geil geil geil geil geil dass das
ist wirklich einfach geil leute dass das
sind meines meiner meinung nach auch die
momente die das leben ausmachen solche
veränderung und solche wege zu sich
selbst zumindest zu sehen wenn man die
nicht selbst erlebt vielleicht noch
nicht selbst erlebt hat zumindest zu
sehen dass andere leute diese wege gehen
dass das ist wirklich so eine der sachen
wo man es geführt ok darum geht es
wirklich im leben und ich habe euch und
so schnell sich das jetzt auch klingen
mag ohne diesen kanal wäre ich heute
nicht dort wo ich bin denn erst als ich
mich mit der wohl unsichersten version
von mir selbst vor die kamera gesetzt
habe und nur ein ganz kleines bisschen
theorie gezeigt habe hat dieser fassade
die ich mir so viele jahre aufgebaut
hatte um mich selbst zu schützen
angefangen mit brücke und die positive
die reaktionen waren habe ich von video
zu video mehr von mir gezeigt und
gemerkt dass dieser hatte nie nötig war
sondern in der ganzen zeit nur davon
abgehalten hat ich selbst zu sein und
damit glücklich zu werden
crazy altar heute wenn ich jetzt bei
diesem video ein bisschen neben der spur
bin und anders bin nämlich sonst sehen
aber das ist einfach richtig richtig
schön zu sehen dass youtube für ihn so
ein befreiendes element hatte und auch
dass seine zuschauer in so akzeptiert
haben also ich weiß nicht wie es euch
geht heute aber oftmals hat man das
gefühl in der welt so viele sachen zu
sehen die schiefgehen wenn dann sachen
mal richtig gehen richtig laufen und
auch noch gefühlt von selbst indem man
einfach der ist der mann ist das ist
wirklich wirklich einfach schön der
kanal hat mich dazu gebracht mich selbst
zu finden und zu lernen stolz auf mich
zu sein ich habe gelernt dass meine
qualität nur ein winzig kleiner
bruchteil von all den tieren tausend
dingen sind die auf mir eine person
machen die wertvolle genauso wie sie es
ich fühle mich so als wäre es endlich
zeit dieses kapitel für mich
abzuschließen ich bin unglaublich stolz
auf mich würde mich heute jemand fragen
was ich gerne an mir ändern würde wäre
es vielleicht dass ich viel zu oft an
mir selbst zweifler oder zu viel wert
auf die meinung anderer legen aber ganz
sicher nicht meine sexualität
auch wenn es für viele nicht mehr so
scheint ich weiß dass noch so viele
unter uns gibt die die gleichen gefühle
wie ich sie hatte jeden tag spüren die
sich verstoßen fühlen einsam und
ungeliebt die sich fragen was hier
eigentlich falsch gemacht habe weil sie
doch eigentlich nur versuchen es allen
recht zu machen die für etwas der das
video das ist wie eine kanonenkugel
leiter
das schlägt voll zu krank das ist
wirklich krank alter ich weiß du gehst
gerade durch die hölle
ich weiß du fragst dich so oft warum du
noch hier wirst ich weiß dass er das
alles nicht verdient hast dass du
überhaupt nichts falsch gemacht hast und
ich weiß dass du richtig bist genauso
wie du
ich sitze hier mit tränen in den augen
und führt euch mein herz aus mir selbst
zu sagen dass alles gut ist und um euch
zu zeigen dass es besser wird immer was
soll man dazu noch sagen leute
unglaubliches video wirklich
unglaubliches video nicht nur weil das
abgegangen ist weil es viele leute
geklickt oder was auch immer sondern
weil das video wirklich wirklich
wirklich power hat und glaube ich
wirklich wirklich einen positiven im
packenden positive auswirkungen auf
viele leute da draußen der satz sei
einfach du selbst ist ein satz der sehr
oft und sehr gerne gesagt wird aber so
einfach ist es am ende dann doch nicht
aber das video hat mir gezeigt wie viel
power da drin ist einfach sich selbst zu
zeigen wie man ist und sich selbst auf
dem weg zu begeben da hin wo man
akzeptieren kann wer man ist ja ich weiß
nicht ob das so weit auch sind für euch
gemacht hat leute ich bin echt doch
mitgenommen so ich hatte einfach eure
kommentare und rhein und bis zum
nächsten mal macht's gut